Clark County students spent their day
learning to trade the trade rather of
law enforcement they heard from officers
analyzed a mock crime scene and dusted
fingerprints Joshua figuero was at a
youth Summit which aims to build
relationships between kids and police
in one of the workshops kids are
learning while law enforcement do as you
see here this is a crime scene kids are
dusting off fingerprints and they're
piecing together what happened that led
to this incident for the third year the
lb MPD Foundation brought students
together for a summit their theme was
law enforcement and I'm just going to
lightly dust they're trying to break
down barriers in the community and it
helps they see that we're all human
beings we have more in common than less
about 95 kids were here at UNLV on
Saturday some of them say this is their
first direct interaction with an officer
I was kind of scared of police I didn't
know I thought they were going to arrest
me or something because if I if I didn't
listen to my mom but now I know more
about the community about what they can
do to help about we can do to help
that's the reason why organizers say
they host a youth Summit so kids could
see the cops are okay
and the cops can see that the kids are
okay that that relationship I think uh
in the future for that young man or
young woman will solve a lot of problems
for it they explored legal careers
working as detective and being a patrol
officer so that's how we start right
just through conversation engagement you
know and and their presence right the
foundation aims for these children to
become the next leaders in law
enforcement so where do you think the
prince would be for some kids however
that's not why they showed up I'm most
excited about the about the eating part
because I'm I'm really excited to see
what's going to be on it maybe some
pizza the Las Vegas Metro Police
Department Foundation is hosting another
event for youth at UNLV on March 25th
Joshua progero eight news now who isn't
always looking for pizza right well
about 12 000 kids have been part of the
lvnpd foundations programs